5 GitHub URL Has That Feel Illegal To Know
1. Change github.com to gitmcp.io
This generates a .mcp config file that you can use to feed your entire project structure to
AI agents like Cursor so that they actually understand your code context without hallucinating.
2. Replace hub with ingest
This turns the entire repository into a single text prompt.
It is perfect for passing a massive code base into ChatGPT, Cloud, or Gemini.
3. Change github.com to gitdiagram.com
This instantly turns your code into a visual flowchart
so you can understand the architecture without reading a single line.
4. Change github to githubbox.com
This opens the repo in code sandbox so that you can actually run and test the project
in the browser without cloning it.
Finally, just press dot on your keyboard or change com to dev.
This opens a full VS Code editor right in the browser.
This feels like cheat codes.
Comment link and I'll send you the detailed list.